our surface just died can Microsoft's
new Surface laptop 5 compete with the M2
MacBook Air well we are going to compare
everything from performance design
speakers webcam and much more both of
these laptops are charged to 100 so what
I'm gonna do is unplug the magsafe
connector and Microsoft's surface
connector because we're also going to
look at battery life throughout this
test here are the full specs of the
laptops and as you guys can see the
price is identical and I actually really
like Microsoft Surface laptops but one
of the biggest issues was the fact that
the ports only supported USB but now
they added Thunderbolt so let's see how
fast it is this is a 92 gigabyte folder
that I'm going to transfer it only has
video files in it so it's very easy for
the computer and now we're transferring
at just over one gigabyte a second the
surface did hit Thunderbolt speeds but
it couldn't maintain it ended up taking
2 minutes and 32 seconds the Mt MacBook
Air on the other hand is flying right
there at two gigabytes a second and that
took less than 59 seconds more than
twice as fast I'm honestly surprised by
these results and that just shows that
just because as Thunderbolt doesn't mean
that it is insanely Fast And for those
of you guys that say that it might not
be in best performance I did switch to
that because sometimes Windows laptops
will slow down transfers if you don't
have it both of these have 512 gigabyte
ssds so let's go ahead and see what the
SSD speeds look like the write speed on
the surface is higher than the Macbook
so we weren't limited for that
Thunderbolt test but there each speed
slightly faster on the Mac the next test
that I'm running is speedometer 2.0 to
check out snappiness for web browsing
and web-based apps and it looks like the
MacBook is 75 faster in terms of things
like Google Suite Microsoft Office
online and that is a pretty big
difference now how about the performance
for desktop apps well I'm going to run a
geekbench 5 here and the surface laptop
5 has the latest 12 down all the lake
processor that has 10 cores and it's
designed for performance and efficiency
alright guys we have a result and I am
thoroughly impressed by the surface for
single core we only have a difference of
12 and for multi-core that is a
difference of 17
now we'll see how it does in other tasks
and plugged in later in the video now
what about the graphics for compute
tasks which so many apps nowadays use
wow guys this is a huge difference we
have 30 000 compared to thirteen
thousand five hundred the Mac is over
twice as fast or has better performance
now we'll see how this translates to
real world apps that we'll be testing
soon but before that I want to show you
guys this amazing thing from our Channel
partner mob which is not only a carry
sleeve for your Mac or your surface but
it is also a stand because of its unique
origami design Now using its innovative
two-in-one design you can seamlessly
transition from the lap laptop sleeve
bag to a stand right away and it has two
built-in angles 15 degrees and 25 so you
can choose what works best for you it
not only does it hold your laptop but it
has a separate layer design so you have
this pouch section which can store
things like an SD card reader Chargers
little memory cards and even things like
your airpods and the nice thing is when
you're not using the pouch it is
completely flat making for the slim
design moff's laptop sleeve uses this
durable pu material and it is
anti-scratch and anti-slip so your
laptop stays in place Moss Black Friday
coupon will save you up to 60 bucks and
you could be the first to know about
their flash sales by subscribing to
their email go ahead and check it out
using the link in the video description
and now what about sustained performance
we know that the empty MacBook Air is
fanless and it doesn't even have a
proper uh heat block whereas the surface
actually has an active cooling system so
I'm running a single round of cinebench
r25 we'll see what we get and then after
we'll do a long test halfway through our
MacBook is already at 108 degrees
Celsius but what I'm really surprised
about is that the surface is still
running silent and look at that the
performance is a lot closer than I
thought we have a difference once again
of 17 just like in geekbench I'm really
impressed how the surface is keeping up
but now let's run our 10 minute throttle
test and see if the surface is going to
be faster once the MacBook slows down
it's been five minutes and the MacBook
already slowed down to 2.8 gigahertz
down to 15 watts because it's hot
whereas the surface it's running around
82 degrees Celsius at full 25 watts and
I can barely hear the fans using my
thermal camera the macbook's at 47
degrees Celsius at the hottest spot
compared to the surface
49.50 right over there wow that is very
hot there's also a lot more more heat in
general but the surface is getting it
away from that chip our scores are in
and wow Intel has done an incredible job
uh the MacBooks still beat it but by
only four percent and we know if this
test was longer the MacBook would slow
down more than the surface it's
maintaining full performance with very
low temperatures that is impressive and
now I want to get into some real world
things that people do day to day and I'm
going to start out with the speakers and
the webcams both of these have speakers
that are hidden underneath the keyboard
so let's go ahead and take a listen
[Music]
now the surface isn't terrible for a
Windows laptop but the MacBook gets
louder has better highs and much more
bass now as far as the webcams the
surface supports Windows hello and I
definitely prefer that over Touch ID
because of how quick and easy it is to
authenticate now the surface camera only
supports 720p compared to the empty
MacBook airs 1080p so you guys let me
know which one looks better in terms of
video quality and as far as microphones
the surface has dual front-facing
microphones whereas the empty MacBook
Air does not so let me know which one
sounds better down below now we also
have some major display differences but
I'm going to cover that in a bit first I
want to look at Graphics I'm going to
run 3D Marks Wildlife extreme to test
out the gaming performance we have a
result and the MacBook has over twice
the FPS 41.3 compared to
20.15 now of course Windows has a lot
more games but with Mac OS some
developers are starting to take it more
seriously like for example we have
Resident Evil recently next let's do a
quick 3D the render test for a long time
Max were said to be terrible for this
but now with the M1 and M2 chips even
thin and light MacBooks can start to
render the MacBook is done while we're
still waiting for the surface this thing
took under two minutes now that was
using the GPU where as a surface it
cannot it has to use CPU I don't know
why maybe CPU is just way faster anyways
so I'm going to switch to the CPU and
see how long it takes here while we're
waiting for the surface the surface is
done and that took five minutes and
basically eight seconds more than two
and a half times longer than the Mac now
switching to CPU this took 4 minutes and
42 seconds so it pretty much is Just
slightly faster but having the graphics
is really helpful and now let's see what
happens with photo editing I have
Lightroom opened up here with these high
resolution files now switching through
performance seems fairly similar let's
try the sky selection here
bam the Mac is done
surface is still waiting I should have
done a timer probably about three times
longer wow and now I'm gonna export
these 50 raw images to jpeg now you guys
saw the CPU performance is very close
both 16 gigs of RAM let's see how they
do dang the MacBook is flying compared
to the surface even though some of those
previous benchmarks show that they're
close bam the surface is done and it
took more than twice as long so if
you're a photo editor the Mac is a
no-brainer now what about video editing
I have DaVinci Resolve here with a 4K
timeline fairly easy footage with some
effects both of them are playing back
smoothly but the surface has to use more
resources to do so let's try an effect
now I'm going to stabilize this clip the
Mac is flying it is going so fast oh my
goodness I um I miss the timer there by
second the Mac took five and a half
seconds compared to 12.5 path and any
sort of effects are going to be way
faster now let's go ahead and Export
this five minute project bam and we are
off I know it's hard to see because of
Windows scaling sucks but we're at 28
frames per second compared to 82 or so
on the Mac the fanless Mac took a minute
and 27 seconds while we're still waiting
for the surface and the surface is
finally done taking 4 minutes and 42
seconds that is over three times longer
than the Mac now you guys see all the
performance is way better on the Macbook
so if you care about that at all well
you should have the Mac but what about
the other things as far as the screens
both of them are very detailed but the
surface has a 3x2 aspect ratio which I
actually prefer now in terms of screen
brightness the MacBook is slightly
brighter but what stands out more is
when you're watching content you have
more contrast especially for dark scenes
and we have a massive difference in Reef
reflectivity where the surface still
looks like a mirror they have not fixed
it and that messes up your contrast
outside it's very hard whereas the
MacBook has great Coatings so as far as
the display the MacBooks is way way
better you guys saw that crazy
difference the only way that the surface
is better other than the aspect ratio
that I personally like is the fact that
is the touchscreen some people really
dig that but then you're gonna have so
many fingerprints with that very
reflective screen now as far as the
design differences you guys can see that
we have the Alcantara right here I
personally like it I know but Dean
doesn't like it but you can get a full
metal one if you want just like the
MacBook now as far as the keyboard the
surface has a great one it feels awesome
just like the keyboard on the Mac but
the max trackpad is so much better more
responsive it's magnetic it is great
whereas the surface one is just about
average the surface used to be sleeker
when he came out but now the Mac has
thinner bezels it is actually lighter
and thinner than the surface and the
footprint is smaller as well with that
we have two thunderbol ports that
transfer much faster we have Max safe
where's the surface only has one of
those ports but it does give you a
regular USB and somehow even though the
MacBook is smaller and lighter it has a
slightly larger battery and with that
let's go ahead and see the results of
our battery life comparison throughout
this video we have been shooting for
three and a half hours running all of
those tests
our surface just died it was at one
percent battery life and it shut off
let's see what her MacBook has now I
actually re-ran blender with a CPU which
I didn't do here so we were doing more
stuff I was looking stuff up and we have
46 battery life when the surface died so
guys that's all almost twice as good
battery life and I actually did more
tasks so with all that said with these
laptops being priced the same Seventeen
hundred dollars who would buy the
surface well it's a decent Windows
laptop but when you have a Mac for this
same price offering all the better
performance better speakers better
almost everything it is just a
no-brainer as long as you don't need
Windows natively you can still use
parallels like we showed off in a
different video and you can still access
certain things like that but this is
just showing why apple is selling so
many of these laptops even now they have
some of them discounted which will link
down below it is an amazing machine I'll
still recommend the surface to some
people that need Windows but for most
just get a Mac go ahead and click that
Circle above to subscribe check out one
of those great videos right over there
check out moff sleeve down below this
one Max I'll see you in the next video
foreign